If you're using clawed code and its lack
of memory makes it feel like you're
starting every single session from
scratch, then you got to check out this
one tool that can fix all your problems.
And that tool is Obsidian. It's free.
It's simple to use. And it's going to
help us unlock persistent memory for
clawed code all while boosting our
performance in the process. This allows
us to do things that other tools like
Open Claw claim to do yet fail
completely at, like actually remember
things about us and act in a way that a
real human personal assistant would.
Now, Obsidian is one of those rare tools
that really does feel like a value ad
across the board. So, I'm really excited
for this lesson. So, let's just hop into
it. So, let's first talk about what
Obsidian actually is. Obsidian is an
orchestration layer, an organization
layer on top of your markdown files in a
specific folder known as a vault.
Obsidian is free. It is not open source,
but everything we create and use with
Obsidian is ours, right? We own it.
Obsidian does it. There's no vendor
lock. This isn't like Notion. And the
real value ad for Obsidian from our
point of view is its ability for us to
see how our different notes and files
and folders connect. So if I have
something open right here, you can see
how this connects to other related notes
and files, right? And you can see over
here on the right, we also have these
like visual graphs that show us how
different documents and projects relate
to one another. Obsidian also has a huge
plug-in community. So everything that
you'll see today is just on the base
level Obsidian, but there are 2736
ways to spice it up if you want to. But
why should you care about any of that?
How does Obsidian actually relate to you
and claude code and your productivity?
Well, to answer that question, you need
to understand the symbiotic relationship
between these two things and you. So,
first and foremost, we have Obsidian and
you. What do you get out of this
relationship? Well, you get what I just
saw, right? The ability to look at files
and click through it and see how they
connect and have like visual insight
between all of your folders and notes.
The problem is for me to actually do
this and get the full value from
Obsidian as a user, I have to actually
draft up all these markdown files and I
have to draft them up in a specific way
that they link, right? I have to like
make sure, hey, I do the double
brackets, I find the note I want, I link
it, right? Pain in the butt. You're
never going to do this in reality,
right? No one's manually doing this in
today's day and age. Enter obviously
Claude Code. Claude Code will do all of
that for us. Claude Code essentially
supercharges the Obsidian experience for
you because whatever you tell Claude
Code, whether that's through text or
prompts or brain dubs or just, you know,
verbal diarrhea, right? Whatever you
give Claude Code, it's going to turn
that into a proper markdown file in the
Obsidian format. Link it all together so
you, the end user, can get better
insights into your notes and your
projects and your thoughts. What if
that's all it did? Well, you still
really wouldn't care, right? Neat. I can
see more of my thoughts. I already know
my thoughts. They're in my brain. How
does this affect claw code? Well, by
virtue of creating an organized
hierarchy of your notes and actually
connecting them all, Obsidian improves
Claude code. Now, think of all this in
terms of Claude Code acting as a
personal assistant for you. And I use
that demonstration on purpose because
that's the sort of use case where you
will get the most value add in this
sorts of situation because when it comes
to personal context, it's very wide in
terms of breadth and the things you're
talking about. Think of like daily notes
and random projects you're working on,
things you're just throwing claudes
away, right? Huge breadth and it
compounds over time, right? So if we're
just talking about daily notes for a
couple weeks, easy enough. How about
daily notes for a couple years, right?
These things add up. And so by having an
organized system of these notes and
having them linked together and they
actually like make sense when you look
at them, this helps claude code, right?
Because when you ask it to do stuff and
gain insights on things and essentially
find relationships between documents, it
helps to have that organization because
that helps cloud code that helps you,
right? Whatever gives cloud code better
performance and insight, ultimately that
rolls downhill. And hopefully by getting
better insights from cloud code based on
your interactions with cloud code, that
will improve interactions down the line,
which will then become files that are
properly notated and organized inside of
Obsidian, which then come to you who can
actually see them. And this whole thing
isn't just a black box. That's the value
ad here with Obsidian. Obsidian is
supercharged by Claude Code by virtue of
organizing your files. That improves
Claude Code's performance, which
ultimately makes you happy. That's the
relationship. That's what this is all
about. Now, you might be thinking,
"That's all well and good, Chase, but
like, can't I just have a giant file
system and throw Markdown files in there
forever and ever and ever and won't claw
code being as effective as it is, still
be able to handle all those files?" The
answer is yes to a certain degree. And
this is kind of like a spectrum, right?
Like on one hand, you can be the average
user over here on the left who's very
lazy and uses cloud code as a personal
assistant. You just throw crap at at it.
And if you think of it as like being in
a warehouse with all of your files and
data, like you just have papers on the
ground, right? They're just thrown
everywhere. Cloud code is good enough to
handle this, although that
disorganization does come at a cost. The
other cost is to you, right? This then
becomes a black box. You as the human
cannot possibly sift through all that
information, right? So you aren't
operating at full capacity and neither's
cloud code. On the other end of the
spectrum, right, we could get we could
go away from just markdown files in a
folder system and we can instead go nuts
and create some sort of like graph rag
system, right? This nuclear bomb
approach that's going to have embeddings
and analysis and all this stuff. The
problem is if we do the rag approach for
most people that's too much and it's
also too much to expect from them to be
able to build and maintain that right if
over here you know we have papers thrown
on the ground this is the library of
congress right you don't need that what
we need is a happy medium right and what
is that happy medium in most cases well
it's actually obsidian because instead
of papers on the ground or the library
of congress I just want like a filing
cabinet that's kind of organized for me
and the offer here is Obsidian is going
to be the filing cabinet and It's a
filing cabinet that is free both in
terms of actual cost and it's not like
this is costing us tokens. This isn't
some sort of heavy framework on top of
cloud code changing how we interact with
it. This is kind of honestly free value,
you know, and it's not free value in
terms of like, oh, if you use Obsidian
after this video, your life's going to
change and you're going to be able to do
projects you couldn't. Not really. But
it's one of these on the margin plays
that I think are kind of rare and that
like it's almost just like a straight
plus with no negatives, right? Someone's
walking down the street, they're just
going to hand you 20 bucks. Are you
going to say no because it's not a h
100red bucks? Absolutely not. You're
going to take it. So, this video is
about how do we take that $20 and use
it? Now, to use it, we first need to
download it. So, you're just going to
head to obsidian.md or just Google
Obsidian. Go to the download page and
download and run through the installer.
It's going to ask you a couple question.
And it's going to ask you where do you
want your vault and what do you want to
call it. So the vault is just a folder
where essentially the Obsidian
orchestration is going to live. The
folder could be anywhere on your
computer. It could be on your desktop.
So you just have the folder. It's known
as Obsidian's vault, but you don't have
to call it the vault for this demo. It
is literally called the vault. And
inside of that folder, that's where all
our markdown files are going to be. So
the vault could have subfolders like,
you know, daily notes, research, and
projects. And inside daily notes are the
markdown files, right? All of the daily
notes for that particular day as just
text documents. And like you saw, if I
click on those text documents, I have
the Obsidian document. When I say
Obsidian document, I'm talking about
this, right? We can look at this inside
of something like our terminal or we can
actually open up Obsidian and look at
it. Same thing. So, after you download
it, just decide where you want the vault
to live. I suggest putting it wherever
you put most of your Claude code
projects. And now to have this
relationship with Obsidian Cloud Code,
you will just start a new project inside
of that vault. Once you create the
vault, all you have to do is open your
terminal, navigate to a folder inside
the vault, or just be in the vault
itself and start up cloud code. You can
see here I'm inside mine, users chase
the vault, and over here on the left
hand side, you can see all the files and
folders. And this is my personal thing,
and most of it's related to content
creation. So you can see stuff for
research, for projects, for people,
inbox, daily notes, etc., etc. Now, when
I look at these files inside of cursor,
it looks just like a normal markdown
file because that's all it is. Now,
there's certain conventions that
Obsidian follows, but guess who knows
these conventions? Claude Code knows
these conventions. So when you're
working inside the vault, all you have
to do is tellclaude code inside of its
claw.md file and say, "Hey, all markdown
files need to follow obsidian
conventions." Furthermore, there are a
million and one repos out there that
have to do with creating Obsidian skills
for Cloud Code. So, if you want to take
it a step further and give Claude code
specific Obsidian skills, just Google
Obsidian skills repos or literally just
tell Claude Code, "Hey, uh, go ahead and
do a web search on the best practices
for Claude code and Obsidian skills and
create those, right? That easy." So, now
let's talk about how we can use this
markdown file setup and this sort of
memory infrastructure to actually
improve Claude code, especially from the
position of a personal assistant. And
the way we're going to do that is
through the claude.md file. And that's
what you're looking at right here. So
remember the claude.md file
traditionally is a file that you use in
your project that essentially lists all
your conventions. You also have the
ability to do something like slashinit,
right? And claude will automatically go
through your entire codebase, figure out
what you're doing and why, and put it in
this file, this claw.md. It almost acts
like a system message in the sense that
claude code is always going to be
looking at this right to make sure it's
doing what you say. Now recently,
relatively le recently, there has been a
big push against things like claw.md
files and slashinit in general. Now this
is in response to this study that came
out last month called evaluating
agents.mmd. Are repository level context
files helpful for coding agents? I'll
put a link to this down below. The long
and short of it is is that this study
pretty much said that using stuff like
Claude MD, these like system message
add-ons that are supposed to enforce
particular conventions are actually a
net negative and they hurt the AI
system. The reason for that is is often
times these conventions don't make sense
with how we actually create projects,
right? oftentimes we're doing like the
UI in one section and the back end in
another section, the authentication in
another place, yet it's constantly
bringing in all the conventions. All
that to say is a lot of people are
saying don't use CloudMD. However, in
the context of a personal assistant
where our conventions don't have to do
with code, they're conventions about how
we think and conventions about how I
want you to write the markdown files in
relation to Obsidian. CloudMD is perfect
for that, right? CloudMD is perfect for
that. And one of the ways Obsidian
allows us to improve this is because all
of these files are already organized. It
is really easy to turn this claw.md file
into a living breathing document. What
you see here is a few weeks of
essentially using Obsidian and Claude
code. I am by no means an Obsidian
expert. I've not been using this for
months and months and months. However, 3
months from now, 6 months from now, 9
months from now, or just like a month
from now, as I continue to add on to
this, one of the great Obsidian Claude
code plays you can do is say, "Hey, take
a look at all our notes. Compare it to
our Claude MD file. Now, make them kind
of match and improve the conventions."
The idea being that your personal
assistant Claude code continues to
become closer and closer to this, you
know, Jarvis type character you want by
virtue of having more information about
you. And in essence, what we get is we
get this brain within a brain, right?
This entire vault system is essentially
your second brain, right? But this
claude MD is like, you know, what
everyone call like the frontal cortex.
It's like this is the one that's
actually making the decisions and it's
distilled our thinking template into one
file and it can always take a look at
the details as needed and this is the
sort of way you should approach the
clawed code and Obsidian relationship.
Now how you ultimately leverage all of
this into something that is useful for
you is obviously up to you. How I've
been using this lately is pretty much
what you saw from my last video. And if
you haven't seen it, it was essentially
using Claude code as a research agent on
steroids in combination with a YouTube
search skill and notebook LM. Well, what
do you think I'm doing with all this
research information I'm gathering from
that workflow? I'm dumping it here into
my second brain to continue to turn
Claude code into my personal research
content assistant. I want it to be. And
in fact, tomorrow's video, at least
that's the plan, is to show you exactly
how to do that. And really what you
should be thinking about in terms of the
use cases is again like if you actually
did have you know your version of
Jarvis, what would it need to know and
what would it need to do and figuring
out how to execute that in this Obsidian
Cloud Code ecosystem is where you're
going to make your money. So this is
where I'm going to leave you guys today.
I hope this video and this conversation
was, if nothing else, able to sort of
shed some light on this relationship
between all three because I think once
you understand how they improve one
another, you get a good grasp of what
Obsidian does and does not buy you
because I think the waters are still
kind of murky for a lot of people. Um,
lastly, as always, hey, if you are
trying to learn more about Claude Code
and you're someone who doesn't come from
a technical background or even someone
who does and essentially trying to
supercharge their process of learning
how to actually use it in a practical
manner, I just released my Claude Code
master class inside of the Chase AI Plus
community. There is a link to that in
the comments. So, make sure you check
that out if you're someone who's serious
about this stuff and is looking to
eventually make it some sort of career.
So, make sure to leave some comments and
let me know what you thought. Also, make
sure to go into the description and
check out the free Chase community.
Again, tons of free resources there if
you're just getting started on your AI
journey. And as always, I'll see you